I asked with all trade deals the real
winners and losers will be the business
owners who are hit by changes in tariffs
and trade laws I'm joined now by John
head ditch who farms in arable crops and
livestock in Somerset so John why
British farm is so nervous about a free
trade deal with the US I don't think
we're particularly worried about a free
trade deal with the u.s. as long as it's
done on equable terms I think what we're
worried about is that we produce to a
very high standard we have a customer
base that expects that sort of standard
and quite frankly the Americans don't
and and they will be able to undercut us
on price and more importantly they'll
undercut us on quality and if the
British farmer loses quality we'll start
to lose the share of of the marketplace
and we ought to be producing all our
food in the UK and not importing it from
from other places where we have no
control over what happens to the quality
of those goods so you're absolutely
convinced then that quality will take a
downturn if a lot of American products
are allowed into the US market that
currently aren't well if things stay as
they are they will because we've already
have a situation where we have hormones
in beef cattle we have chlorine washed
chicken these are things that are
covered by rules and regulations but
those rules and regulations come from
the consumer they're they're things that
our consumer doesn't want they don't
want GM crops they don't want hormones
in beef they don't want chlorine washed
chicken and if we have to concede those
points to make the Americans happy so we
can do deals with them it puts the
agriculture at a quite a disadvantage
but Americans have been eating these
sort of chickens and this kind of beef
and those kind of crops for years
without harming them I mean if people
don't want them they don't have to buy
them do they that's absolutely right so
it goes along with with labeling and and
other bits of legislation I'm not saying
what what the Americans are eating are
going to be bad for Europeans I'm sure
that won't it's just that our consume
have become quite accustomed to having
the best quality that there is and it
would seem to be very counterproductive
if we we downgrade purely to to make
some American farmer happy Surry votes
for Trump and we all have a trade
agreement we can get to trade agreements
without conceding yung on things like
quality what about the benefits for
British consumers though if American
goods more American products are allowed
in and they've helped push down prices
this is the this is the big big problem
isn't it we've got we've got English
agriculture working on very very tight
margins and very high standards we've
got other countries in the world who
work on even tighter margins possibly in
some cases but who can produce goods
very cheaply and the standards aren't
there and we as society we as a nation
have got to make up our minds whether we
want really cheap and cheerful or which
case a lot of English agriculture will
go to the wall but that won't matter
because we can buy it cheaper in the
world or we actually hold our standards
high we produce to the best quality that
we possibly can and we deliver value for
money for the consumer